The phone and content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ETHAN MEYERS: What I'm
talking about today
is neural population
decoding, which
is very similar to what
Rebecca was talking about,
except for I'm talking about now
more on the single neuron level
and also talk a bit about
some MEG at the end.
But kind of to tie it to what
was previously discussed,
Rebecca talked a lot about, at
the end, the big catastrophe.
Well, you don't know
if something is not
there in the fMRI signal because
things could be masked when
you're averaging
over a large region
as you do when you're recording
from those bold signals.
And when you're doing
decoding on single neurons,
that is not really an issue
because you're actually
going down and recording
those individual neurons.
And so while in general
in hypothesis testing
you can never really say
something doesn't exist,
here you can feel fairly
confident that it probably
doesn't, unless you--
I mean, you could do
a Bayesian analysis.
Anyway, all right.
So kind of the very basic
motivation behind what I do
is, you know, I'm interested in
all the questions the CBMM is
interested in, how can we
algorithmically solve problems
and perform behaviors.
And so, you know,
basically as motivation,
you know, as a theoretician,
we might have some great idea
about how the brain works.
And so what we do is we
come up with an experiment
and we run it.
And we record a
bunch of neural data.
And then at the end of
it, what we're left with
is just a bunch of data.
It's not really an
answer to our question.
So for example, if
you recorded spikes,
you might end up with
something called a raster
where you have trials and time.
And you just end up with
little indications at what
times did a neuron spike.
Or if you did an
MEG experiment, you
might end up with a bunch
of kind of waveforms
that are kind of noisy.
And so this is a
good first step,
but obviously what
you need to do
is take this and turn it
into some sort of answer
to your question.
Because if you can't
turn it into an answer
to your question,
there is no point
in doing that experiment
to begin with.
So basically, what
I'm looking for is
clear answers to questions.
In particular I'm
interested in two things.
One is neural content.
And that is what information
is in a particular region
of the brain, and at what time.
And the other thing
I'm interested in
is neural coding, or what
features of the neural activity
contain that information.
And so the idea is, basically,
if we can make recordings
from a number of
different brain regions
and tell what content was
in different parts, then
we could, basically,
trace the information flow
through the brain
and try to unravel
the algorithms that enable us
to perform particular tasks.
And then if we can do that,
we can do other things
that the CBMM likes
to do, such as build
helpful robots that will
either bring us drinks
or create peace.
So the outline
for the talk today
is I'm going to talk about what
neural population decoding is.
I'm going to show
you how you can
use it to get at neural
content, so what information
is in brain regions.
Then I'm going to show how you
can use it to answer questions
about neural coding, or how do
neurons contain information.
And then I'm going to show you
a little bit how you can use
it to analyze your own data.
So very briefly, a
toolbox I created
that makes it easy
to do these analyses.
All right, so the basic
idea behind neural decoding
is that what you
want to do is you
want to take neural activity
and try to predict something
about the stimulus
itself or about,
let's say, an animal's behavior.
So it's a function that
goes from neural activity
to a stimulus.
And decoding approaches
have been used for maybe
about 30 years.
So Rebecca was saying
MBPA goes back to 2001.
Well, this goes
back much further.
So in 1986, Georgopoulos
did some studies
with monkeys showing
that he could
decode where a monkey
was moving its arm based
on neural activity.
And there was other
studies in '93
by Matt Wilson and McNaughton.
Matt gave a talk here,
I think, as well.
And what he tried
to do is decode
where a rat is in a maze.
So again, recording
from the hippocampus,
trying to tell
where that rat is.
And there's also been a large
amount of computational work,
such as work by Selinas and
Larry Abbott, kind of comparing
different decoding methods.
But despite all of this work,
it's still not widely used.
So Rebecca was saying that
MVPA has really taken off.
Well, I'm still waiting
for population decoding
in neural activity to take off.
And so part of me
being up here today
is to say you really
should do this.
It's really good.
And just a few other
names for decoding
is MVPA, multi variant
pattern analysis.
This is the terminology that
people in the fMRI community
use and what Rebecca was using.
It's also called read out.
So if you've heard
those terms, it kind of
refers to the same thing.
All right, so let
me show you what
decoding looks like in terms of
an experiment with, let's say,
a monkey.
So here we'd have an experiment
where we're showing the monkey
different images on a screen.
And so for example, we could
show it a picture of a kiwi.
And then we'd be making
some neural recordings
from this monkey,
so we'd get out
a pattern of neural activity.
And what we do in decoding
is we feed that pattern
of neural activity
into a machine learning
algorithm, which we call
pattern classifiers.
Again, you've all
heard a lot about that.
And so what this
algorithm does, is
it learns to make an association
between this particular
stimulus and this particular
pattern of neural activity.
And so then we repeat that
process with another image,
get another pattern of
neural activity out.
Feed that into the classifier.
And again, it learns
that association.
And so we do that for every
single stimulus in our stimulus
set.
And for multiple repetitions
of each stimulus.
So you know, once this
association is learned,
what we do is we
use the classifier
or test the classifier.
Here we show another image.
We get another pattern
of neural activity out.
We feed that into
the classifier.
But this time, instead
of the classifier
learning the association,
it makes a prediction.
And here it predicted the
kiwi, so we'd say it's correct.
And then we can repeat
that with a car,
get another pattern
of activity out.
Feed it to the classifier,
get another prediction.
And this time the
prediction was incorrect.
It predicted a face, but
it was actually a car.
And so what we do is
we just note how often
are predictions correct.
And we can plot that
as a function of time
and kind of see the
evolution of information
as it flows through
a brain region.
All right, so in reality,
what we usually do is actually
we run the full experiment.
So we actually have collected
all the data beforehand.
And then what we do is we split
it up into different splits.
So here we had, you know,
this experiment, let's say,
was faces and cars or something.
So we have different
splits that have
two repetitions of the
activity of different neurons
do two faces and two cars, and
there's three different splits.
And so what we do is we
take two of the splits
and train the classifier, and
then have the remaining split
and test it.
And we do that for all
permutations of leaving out
a different test split.
So you all heard about
cross-validation before?
OK.
One thing to note about
neural populations
is when you're
doing decoding, you
don't actually need to record
all the neurons simultaneously.
So I think this might be one
reason why a lot of people
haven't jumped on the technique
because they feel like you need
to do these massive recordings.
But you can actually do
something what's called pseudo
populations, where you build up
a virtual population that you
pretend was recorded
simultaneously but really
wasn't.
So what you do with that is
you just, if on the first day
you recorded one neuron,
and the second day
you recorded the
second neuron, etc.
What you can do is you
can just randomly select,
let's say, one trial
when a kiwi was
shown from the first
day, another trial
from the second day, et cetera.
You randomly pick them.
And then you can just build
up this virtual population.
And you can do that for
a few examples of kiwis,
a few examples of cars.
And then you just train and test
your classifier like normal.
But this kind of broadens
the applicability.
And then you can ask
questions about what
is being lost by doing
this process versus if you
had actually done the
simultaneous recordings.
And we'll discuss that
a little bit more later.
So I'll give you an
example of one classifier,
again, I'm sure
you've seen much more
sophisticated and
interesting methods
but I'll show you a
very basic one that I
have used a bit in the past.
It's called the maximum
correlation coefficient
classifier.
It's, again, very similar to
what Rebecca was talking about.
But all you do is--
let's say this is
our training set.
So we have four
vectors for each image,
each thing we want to classify.
And all we're going
to do is we're
going to take the
average across neurons
to reduce these four
vectors into a single factor
for each stimulus.
OK, so if we did that we'd
get one kind of prototype
of each of the stimuli.
And then to test the classifier,
all we're going to do
is we're going to
take a test point
and we're going to do the
correlation between this test
point and each of the
kind of prototype vectors.
Whichever one has the
highest correlation,
we're going to say
that's the prediction.
Hopefully pretty simple.
The reason we often use
fairly simple classifiers,
such as the maximum correlation
coefficient classifier,
is because--
or at least one
motivation is because it
can be translated into what
information is directly
available to a downstream
population that
is reading the information
in the population you
have recordings from.
So you could actually
view what the classifier
learns as synaptic
weights to a neuron.
You could view the
pattern of activity
you're trying to classify as
the pre-synaptic activity.
And then by doing this dot
product multiplication, perhaps
pass through some
non-linearity, you
can kind of output a
prediction about whether there
is evidence for a particular
stimulus being present.
All right, so let's go into
talking about neural content,
or what information
is in a brain region
and how it needs
decoding to get at that.
So as motivation, I'm
going to be talking
about a very simple experiment.
Basically, this experiment
involves a monkey
fixating on a point for--
well, through the
duration of the trial.
But first, there's
a blank screen.
And then after 500 milliseconds,
up is going to come a stimulus.
And for this
experiment, there is
going to be 7 different possible
stimuli that are shown here.
And what we're going
to try to decode
is which of these stimuli
was present on one
particular trial.
And we're going to do that
as a function of time.
And the data I'm
going to use comes
from the inferior
temporal cortex.
We're going to look at 132
neuron pseudo populations.
This was data recorded by Ying
Jang in Bob Desimone's lab.
It's actually part of a
more complicated experiment
but I've just reduced it here to
the simplest kind of bare bones
nature.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to basically train
the classifier on one time
point with the average
firing rate in some bin.
I think in this case
it's 100 milliseconds.
And then we're going to
test at that time point.
And then I'm going to slide
over by a small amount
and repeat that process.
So each time we are repeating
training and testing
the classifier.
Again, 100 milliseconds
sampled every 10 seconds,
or sliding every 10 seconds.
And this will give us a flow
of information over time.
So during the baseline
period we should not
be able to decode
what's about to be seen,
unless the monkey is
psychic, in which case
either there is something
wrong with your experiment,
most likely.
Or you should go to Wall
Street with your monkey.
But you know, you shouldn't
get anything here.
And then we should see
some sort of increase
here if there is information.
And this is kind of what it
looks like from the results.
So this is zero.
After here, we should
see information.
This is chance, or 1 over 7.
And so if we try this
decoding experiment,
what we find is
during the baseline,
our monkey is not psychic.
But when we put
on a stimulus, we
can tell what it is pretty
well, like almost perfectly.
Pretty simple.
All right, we can also
do some statistics
to tell you when the decoding
results are above chance doing
some sort of permutation test
where we shuffle the labels
and try to do the decoding
on shuffled labels where
we should get chance
decoding performance.
And then we can see where is our
real result relative to chance,
and get p values and
things like that.
It's pretty simple.
How does this stack up
against other methods
that people commonly use?
So here's our decoding
result. Here's another method.
Here I'm applying an
ANOVA to each neuron
individually and counting
the number of neurons that
are deemed to be selective.
And so what you see is that
there's basically no neurons
in the baseline period.
And then we have a huge number.
OK, so it looks
pretty much identical.
We can compute mutual
information on each neuron
and then average that together
over a whole bunch of neurons.
Again, looks pretty simple.
Or similar, I should say.
Or we can compute a
selectivity index.
Take the best stimulus, subtract
from the worst stimulus,
divide by the sum.
Again, looks similar.
So there's two
takeaway messages here.
First of all, why do decoding if
all the other methods work just
as well?
And I'll show you in a
bit, they don't always.
And then the other
take away message
though is as a reassurance,
it is giving you
the same thing, right?
So you know we're
not completely crazy.
It's a sensible thing to
do in the most basic case.
One other thing
decoding can give you
that these other methods can't
is something called a confusion
matrix.
So a confusion matrix,
Rebecca kind of talked
a little bit about
related concepts,
basically what you have is you
have the true classes here.
So this is what was actually
shown on each trial.
And this is what your
classifier predicted.
So the diagonal elements
mean correct predictions.
There actually was a car
shown and you predicted a car.
But you can look at the
off diagonal elements
and you can see what was
commonly made as a mistake.
And this can tell you,
oh, these two stimuli
are represented in a similar
way in a brain region, where
the mistakes are happening.
So another kind of
methods issue is,
what is the effect of using
different classifiers?
If the method is highly
dependent on the classifier you
use, then that's
not a good thing
because you're not
telling yourself
anything about the
data, but you're really
telling you something
about the method
you use to extract that data.
But in general, for at least
simple decoding questions,
it's pretty robust to the choice
of classifier you would use.
So here is the maximum
correlation coefficient
classifier I told you about.
Here's a support vector machine.
You can see like almost
everything looks similar.
And like when there's
something not working as well,
it's generally a
slight downward shift.
So you get the same
kind of estimation
of how much information is
in a brain region flowing
as a function of time.
But maybe your absolute accuracy
is just a little bit lower
if you're not using
the optimal method.
But really, it seems like we're
assessing what is in the data
and not so much
about the algorithm.
So that was decoding
basic information
in terms of content.
But I think one of the most
powerful things decoding
can do is it can
decode what I call
abstract or
invariant information
where you can get an assessment
of whether that's present.
So what does that mean?
Well, basically you can think of
something like the word hello.
It has many different
pronunciations
in different languages.
But if you speak these
different languages,
you can kind of
translate that word
into some sort of meaning
that it's a greeting.
And you know how to
respond appropriately.
So that's kind of a
form of abstraction.
It's going from very
different sound concepts
into some sort of
abstract representation
where I know how to respond
appropriately by saying hello
back in that language.
Or another example of this kind
of abstraction or invariance
is the invariance of
the pose of a head.
So for example, here is a bunch
of pictures of Hillary Clinton.
You can see her head is
at very different angles.
But we can still tell
it's Hillary Clinton.
So we have some sort of
representation of Hillary
that's abstracted from the
exact pose of her head,
and also abstracted from
the color of her pantsuit.
It's very highly
abstract, right?
So that's pretty powerful to
know how the brain is dropping
information in order to build
up these representations that
are useful for behavior.
And I think if we
were, again, going
to build intelligent
robotic system,
we'd want to build it
to have representations
that have become more abstract
so it can perform correctly.
So let's show you
the example of how
we can assess abstract
representations in neural data.
What I'm going to look at
is position invariance.
So this is similar
to a study that
was done in 2005 by Hung
and Kreiman in Science.
And what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to train the classifier
with data at an upper location.
So in this experiment,
the stimuli
was shown at three
different locations.
So on any given
trial, one stimulus
was shown at one location.
And these three
locations were used,
so the 7 objects were all
shown at the upper location,
or at the middle, at the lower.
And here I'm training
the classifier
using just the trials
when the stimuli was
shown in the upper location.
And then what we can do is we
can then test the classifier
on those trials where
the stimuli were just
shown at the lower location.
And we can see, if we train
at the upper location,
does it generalize to
the lower location.
And if it does, it means there
is a representation that's
invariant to position.
Does that make
sense to everyone?
So let's take a
look at the results
for training at the upper
and testing at the lower.
They're down here.
So here again, I'm training
at the upper location.
And this is the results
from testing at the lower.
Here is chance.
And you can see we're well
above chance in the decoding.
So it's generalizing from the
upper location to the lower.
We can also train at the upper
and test at the same upper,
at the middle location.
And what we find is
this pattern of results.
So we're getting best results
when we train and test
at exactly the same position.
But we can see it does
generalize to other positions
as well.
And so we can do this full
permutations of things.
So here we trained
at the upper, we
could also train at the middle,
or train at the lower location.
And here if we
train at the middle,
we get the best decoding
performance when
we decode at that same middle.
But again, it's generalizing to
the upper and lower locations,
and the same for
training at lower.
Get the best performance
testing lower,
but it again generalizes.
So if you want to just conclude
this one mini study here,
you know, information in
IT is position invariant
but not you know 100%.
So we can use this technique.
I'll show you a
few other examples
of how it can be used in
slightly more powerful ways,
maybe, or to answer slightly
more interesting questions.
So what another question
we might want to ask,
actually we did ask in this
paper that just came out,
was about the question
of pose invariant
identity information,
so that same question
about can a brain region
respond to Hillary Clinton
regardless of where
she's looking.
And so this is data recorded
by Winrich Freiwald and Doris
Tsao.
Winrich probably already
talked about this experiment.
But what they did was they
had the face system here
where they found
these little patches
through fMRI that respond more
to faces than other stimuli.
They went in and they
recorded from these patches.
And in this study that we're
going to look at, they did a--
they used these stimuli that
had 25 different individuals
shown at eight different
head orientations.
So this is Doris at eight
different head orientations,
but there were 24 other
people who also were shown.
And so what I'm
going to try to do
is decode between the 25
different people and see,
can it generalize if I
train at one orientation
and test at a different one.
And the three brain
regions we're going to use
is the most posterior region.
So in this case, the eyes
out here, this is like V1.
This is the ventral pathway.
So the most posterior region,
we can combine ML and MF.
We compare that to AL and to AM.
I'm going to see how much
position variance is there.
So again, like I said,
let's start by training
on the left profile
and then we can
test on the left profile
in different trials.
Or we can test on a
different set of images
where the individuals were
looking straight forward.
So here are the results from the
most posterior region, ML/MF.
What we see is if we
train in the left profile
and test on the
left profile here,
we're getting results that
are above chance, as indicated
by the lighter blue trace.
But if we train on the
left profile and test
in the straight
results, we're getting
results that are at chance.
So this patch here is not
showing very much pose
invariance.
So let's take a look at
the rest of the results.
So this is ML/MF.
If we look at AL,
what we see is,
again, there's a big advantage
for training and testing
at that same orientation.
But now we're seeing
generalization
to the other orientations.
You're also seeing this "U"
pattern where you're actually
generalizing better
from one profile
to the opposite profile,
which was reported in some
of their earlier papers.
But yeah, here you're
seeing, statistically,
that is above chance.
Now it's not huge,
but it's above what
you'd expect by chance.
And if we look at
AM as well, we're
seeing a higher degree
of invariance, again,
a slight advantage to the exact
pose, but still pretty good.
Again, this "U" a
little bit but yeah,
we're going to the
back of the head.
So what would that
tell you, the fact
that it's going to the
back of the head, tells you
it's probably representing
something about hair.
What I'm going to do next,
rather than just training
at the left profile, I'm going
to take the results of training
at each of the profiles and
either testing at the same
or testing at a
different profile.
And then I'm going to plot
it as a function of time.
So here are the results
of training and testing
at the same pose.
So the non-invariant case.
This is ML/MF.
And this AL and AM.
So this is going from the
back of the head anterior.
And what you see
is there is a kind
of an increase in this
pose-specific information.
Here the increase
is fairly small.
But there is just
generally more information
as you're going down.
But the big increase is
really in this pose invariant
information.
When you train at one
location and test at another,
that's these red traces here.
And here you can see it's
really accelerating a lot.
It's really that these
areas downstream are maybe
pooling over the different
poses to create opposing
invariant representation.
So to carry on with this for
general concept of testing
invariant representations
or abstract representations,
let me just give you one
more example of that.
Here was one of my
earlier studies.
What I did was this study was
looking at categorization.
It was a study done
in Earl Miller's lab.
David Friedman
collected the data.
And what they did was
they trained a monkey
to group a bunch of images
together and called them cats.
And then to group a number
of images together and called
them dogs.
It wasn't clear that
the images necessarily
were more similar to each
other within a category
versus out of the category.
But through this
training, the monkeys
could quite well group the
images together in a delayed
match to sample task.
And so what I
wanted to know was,
is there information that is
kind of about the animal's
category that is abstracted
away from the low level
of visual features.
OK, so was this
learning process,
did they build neural
representations that
are more similar to each other?
So what I did here was I
trained the classifier on two
of the prototype images.
And then I tested it on
a left out prototype.
And so if it's making
correct predictions here,
then it is generalizing
to something
that would only be available
in the data if the monkey had--
due to the monkey's training.
Modulo any low level compounds.
And so here is decoding of
this abstract or invariant
information from the two areas.
And what you see,
indeed, there seems
to be this kind of
grouping effect, where
the category is represented
both in IT and PFC
in this abstract way.
So the same method can be
used to assess learning.
So just to summarize
the neural content part,
decoding offers a way to clearly
see what information is there
and how it is flowing
through a brain region
as a function of time.
We can assess basic
information and often it
yields similar results
to other methods.
But we can also do
things like assess
abstract or invariant
information, which
is not really possible
with other methods
as far as I can see how to
use those other methods.
So for neural coding, my
motivation is the game poker.
This one study I did.
Basically, when I moved to
Boston I learned how to play
Texas Hold'em.
It's a card game where, you
know-- it's a variant of poker,
I'm sure most of you know,
I didn't know the rules
before but I learned the rules.
And I could play the
game pretty successfully
in terms of at least applying
those rules correctly,
not necessarily in
terms of winning money.
But I knew what to do.
And prior to that, I
had known other games
like Go Fish, or
War, or whatever.
And me learning
how to play poker
did not disrupt my
ability to play go fish.
I was still bad at that as well.
So somehow this information that
allowed me to play this game
had to be added
into my brain if we
believe brains cause behavior.
And so in this study, we're kind
of getting at that question,
what changed about a brain to
allow it to perform a new task?
And so to do this in an
experiment with monkeys,
basically, they
used a paradigm that
had two different phases to it.
The first phase, what they
did, was they had a monkey just
do a passive fixation task.
So what the monkey
did was, there
would be a fixation
dot that came up.
Up would come a stimulus.
There would be a delay.
There would be a
second stimulus.
And there would
be a second delay.
And then there
would be a reward.
And the reward was given just
for the monkey maintaining
fixation.
The monkey did not
need to pay attention
to what the stimuli were at all.
And on some trials the
stimuli was the same.
On other trials,
they were different.
But the monkey did not
need to care about that.
So monkey does
this passive task.
They record like
over 750 neurons
from the prefrontal cortex.
And then what they did was
they trained the monkey
to deal with delayed
match to sample task.
And the delayed match to
sample task ran very similar.
So it had a fixation.
There was a first stimulus.
There was a delay, a second
stimulus, a second delay.
So up to this point,
the sequence of stimuli
was exactly the same.
But now after the
second delay, up came
a choice target, a choice
image, and the monkey
needed to make a saccade
to the green stimulus
if these two stimuli
were matches.
And needed to make a
saccade to the blue stimulus
if they were different.
And so what we wanted to
know was when the monkey is
performing this task, it
needs to remember the stimuli
and whether they
were matched or not,
is there a change in
the monkey's brain.
And so the way we're
going to get at this
is, not surprisingly,
doing a decoding approach.
And what we do is we're going
to use the same thing where
we train to classify
at one point in time,
test, and move on.
And what we should
find is that we're
going to try to decode
whether to stimuli
matched or did not match.
And so at the time when the
second stimulus was shown,
we should have some sort
of information about
whether it was a
match or non-match
if any information is present.
And we can see, was
that information there
before when the monkey was
just passively fixating,
or does that information
come on only after training.
So here is a schematic of
the results for decoding.
It's a binary task,
whether a trial
was a match or a non-match.
So chance is 50% if
you were guessing.
This light gray shaded
region is the time
when the first stimuli came on.
This second region is the time
the second stimulus came on.
And here is where we're
kind of going to ignore,
this was either the
monkey was making a choice
or got a juice reward.
We just ignore that.
So let's make this interactive.
How many people thought
there was-- or think
there might be information about
whether the two stimuli match
or do not match prior to the
monkey doing the tasks, so
just in the pacification task?
Two, three, four, five--
how many people
think there was not?
OK, I'd say it's
about a 50/50 split.
OK, so let's look at the
passive fixation task.
And what we find is that there
really wasn't any information.
So there's no blue
bar down here.
So as far as the
decoding could tell,
I cannot tell whether the two
stimuli match or not match
in the passive fixation.
What about in the active
delay match to sample task,
how many people think--
it would be a pretty boring
talk if there wasn't.
what area?
We're talking about
dorsolateral--
actually, both dorsa and ventra
lateral prefrontal cortex.
Yeah, indeed there
was information there.
In fact, we could
decode nearly perfectly
from that brain region.
So way up here at the time when
the second stimulus was shown.
So clearly performing
the task, or learning
how to perform the
task, influenced
what information was present
in the prefrontal cortex.
I'm pretty convinced
that this information
is present and real.
Now the question is,
and why I'm using this
as an example of coding,
how did this information
get added into the population.
We believe it's there
for real and probably
contributing to behavior
it's a pretty big effect.
All right, so here is just
some single neuron results.
What I've plotted
here is this is
a measure of how much of
the variability of a neuron
is predicted about whether a
trial is match or non-match.
And I've plotted
each dot as a neuron.
I've plotted each
neuron at the time
where it had this
maximum value of being
able to predict whether a
trial is match or non-match.
And so this is the passive case.
And so this is kind
of a null distribution
because we didn't
see any information
present about match or
non-match in the passive case.
When the monkey was
performing the delayed match
to sample task, what
you see is that there's
kind of a small
number of neurons
that become selective after
the second stimulus is shown.
So it seems like a few
neurons are carrying
a bunch of the information.
Let's see if we can quantify
this just maybe a little better
using decoding.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to take the
training set and we're
going to do an ANOVA to find,
let's say, the eight neurons
that carry the most information
out of the whole population.
So the 750 neurons,
let's just find
the eight that had the
smallest p value in an ANOVA.
And so we can find
those neurons.
And we can keep them.
And we can delete all
the other neurons.
And then now we
found those neurons,
we'll also go to the test set
and we'll delete those neurons.
And now we'll try doing the
whole decoding procedure
on the smaller population.
And by deleting the neurons
on the training set,
we're not really
biasing our results
when we start doing
the classification.
So here are the results
using all 750 neurons
that I showed you before.
And here are the results using
just the eight best neurons.
And what you can see is
that the eight best neurons
are doing almost as well
as using all 750 neurons.
Now I should say, there
might be a different eight
best at each point
in time because I'm
shifting that bin around.
But still, at any
one point in time
there are eight neurons that
are really, really good.
So clearly there is kind of
this compact or small subset
of neurons that carry the whole
information of the population.
Once you've done
that, you might not
want to know the flip of that,
how many redundant neurons are
there that also carry
that information.
So here are the results,
again, showing all 750 neurons
as a comparison.
And what I'm going
to do now is I'm
going to take those eight
best neurons, find them
in the training
set, throw them out.
I'm going to also
throw another 120
of the best neurons just to
get rid of a lot of stuff.
So I'm going to throw
out the best 128.
And then we'll look at the
remaining neurons and see,
is there redundant
information in those neurons.
It's still like 600
neurons or more.
And so here are the
results from that.
What you see is that there
is also redundant information
in this kind of weaker tail.
It's not quite as good as
the eight best or not as
high decoding
accuracy, but there
is redundant information to it.
Just to summarize this
part, what we see here
is that there is
a few neurons that
really became highly, highly
selective due to this process.
So we see that there's
a lot of information
in this small, compact set.
Here are the results from
a related experiment.
This was in a task
where the monkey had
to remember the spatial
location of a stimuli
rather than what an image
was, like a square or circle.
But anyway, small detail.
Here's this big effect of
this is match information,
this is non-match
information being decoded.
So these are the
decoding results
that I showed you before.
Here's an analysis where an ROC
analysis was done on this data.
So for each neuron,
they calculated
how well does an individual
neuron separate the match
and the non-match trials.
And again, pre
and post training.
And what you see is here, they
did not see this big split
that I saw with the decoding.
And this was published.
So the question is, why
did they not see it.
And the reason is because there
were only a few neurons that
were really highly selective.
That was enough to
drive the decoding
but it wasn't enough if you
averaged over all the neurons
to see this effect.
So essentially, there's kind
of like two populations here.
There's a huge
population of neurons
that did pick up the
match information,
or picked it up very weakly.
And then there's a
small set of neurons
that are very selective.
And so if you take an average
of the nonselective population,
it's just here.
Let's say this is the
pre-training population.
If you take an average
of post-training
over all the
neurons, the average
would shift slightly
to the right.
But it might not
be very detectable
from the pre-training
amount of information.
But if you have weights on just
the highly selective neurons,
you see a huge effect.
So it's really important
that you don't average over
all your neurons but you treat
the neurons as individuals,
or maybe classes, because
they're doing different things.
So the next coding
question I wanted to ask
was, is information
contained in what I
call a dynamic population code.
OK, so let me explain
what that means.
If we showed a stimulus, such
as a kiwi, which I like showing,
we saw that there might be a
unique pattern for that kiwi.
And that pattern
is what enables me
to discriminate between
all the other stimuli
and do the classification.
But it might turn out
that there's not just
one pattern for that
kiwi, but there's actually
a sequence of patterns.
So if we plotted the
patterns in time,
they would actually change.
So it's a sequence of patterns
that represents one thing.
And this kind of thing has
been shown a little bit.
And actually now it's
been shown a lot.
But when I first did this
in 2008, the kind of one
study I knew of
that kind of showed
this was this paper by Ofer
Mazor and Gilles Laurent
where they did kind
of the PCA analysis.
And this is in like the locusts,
I think, olfactory bulb.
And they showed that there
were these kind of trajectories
in space where a particular
odor was represented
by maybe different neurons.
And again, I had a paper in
2008 where I examined this.
And there's a review
paper by King and Dehaene
in 2014 about this.
And there's a lot of
people looking at this now.
So how can we get at this
kind of thing in decoding?
What you can do is you
can train the classifier
at one point in time, and
test it at a point in time
like we were doing before.
But you can also test
at other points in time.
And so what happens is if you
train at a point in time that
should have the information,
and things are contained
in a static code where there's
just one pattern, then if you
test at other points in
time, you should do well.
Because you capture that pattern
where there's good information,
you should do well at
other points in time.
However, if it's a changing
pattern of neural activity,
then when you train
at one point in time,
you won't do well at
other points in time.
Does that make sense?
So here are the results--
if that will go away.
Let me just orient you here.
So this is the same
experiment, you know,
time of the first stimulus, time
of the second stimulus, chance.
This black trace is what we
saw before that I was always
plotting in red.
This is the standard decoding
when I trained and tested
at each point in time.
This blue trace is
where I train here
and I tested all
other points in time.
So if it's the case that
there's one pattern coding
the information, what
you're going to find
is that as soon as that
information becomes present,
it will fill out
this whole curve.
Conversely, if it's
changing, what you might see
is just a localized
information just at one spot.
So let's take a
look at the movie,
if that moves out of the way.
OK, here is the moment of truth.
Information is rising.
And what you see in
this second delay period
is clearly we see this
little peak moving along.
So it's not that
there's just one
pattern that
contains information
at all points in time.
But in fact, it's a
sequence of patterns
that each contain
that information.
So here are the results just
plotted in a different format.
This is what we call a
temporal cross training
plot because I train
at one point and test
at a different point in time.
So this is the time I'm
testing the classifier.
This is the time I'm
training the classifier.
This is the passive
fixation stage,
so there was no information
in the population.
And this is just
how I often plot it.
What you see is there's
this big diagonal band.
Here you see it's
like widening a bit
so it might be hitting some
sort of stationary point there.
But you can see
that clearly there's
these dynamics happening.
And we can go and we can
look at individual neurons.
So these are actually the
three most selective neurons.
They're not randomly chosen.
Red is the firing rate
to the non-match trials.
Blue is the firing rate
to the match trials.
This neuron has a pretty
wide window of selectivity.
This other neuron here
has a really small window.
There's just this little blip
where it's more selective
or has a higher firing rate to
not match compared to match.
And it's these neurons that
have these little kind of blips
that are giving rise
to that dynamics.
Here's something else we can
ask about with the paradigm
of asking coding questions.
What we're going
to do here is we're
going to try a bunch of
different classifiers.
And here, you know,
these are some questions
that kind of came up.
But can we tweak the classifier
to understand a little bit more
about population code.
So here is a fairly
simple example.
But I compared three
different classifiers.
And the question
I wanted to get at
was, is information coded in the
total activity of a population.
Or is it coded more so
in the relative activity
of different neurons.
So you know, in particular,
in the face patches,
we see that information of all
neurons increases to faces.
But if you think
about that from a--
or maybe not information,
but the firing rate
increases to all faces.
But if the firing rate
increases to all faces,
you've lost dynamic range
and you can't really
tell what's happening
for individual faces.
So what I wanted to
know was, how much
information is coded by this
overall shift versus patterns.
So what I did here was I used a
Poisson Naive Bayes classifier,
which takes into account both
the overall magnitude and also
the patterns.
I used a classifier
minimum angle
that took only the
patterns into account.
And I used a classifier
called the total population
activity that only took
the average activity
of the whole population.
This classifier's pretty
dumb, but in a certain sense,
it's what fMRI is
doing, just averaging
all your neurons together.
So it's a little bit of a proxy.
There's paper,
also, by Elias Issa
and Jim DiCarlo where they show
that fMRI is actually fairly--
or somewhat strongly correlated
with the average activity
of a whole population.
So let's see how these
classifiers compare
to each other to see
where the information is
being coded in the activity.
Again, I'm going to use this
study from Doris and Winrich
where we're going to be looking
at the pose specific phase
information, just as an example.
So this is decoding
those 25 individuals
when they're shown,
trained, and tested
that exact same head pose.
And so what we see is we see
that when we use the Poisson
Naive Bayes classifier that
took the pattern and also
the total activity
into account, and when
we used the classifier that took
just the pattern into account,
the minimum angle, we're
getting similar results.
So the overall activity
was not really adding much.
But if you just use the
overall activity by itself,
it was pretty poor.
So this is, again,
touching on something
about what Rebecca said,
when you start averaging,
you can lose a lot.
And so you might be blind
to a lot of what's going on
if you're just using voxels.
There is reasons to do
invasive recordings.
All right, and I think this
might be my last point in terms
of neural coding.
But this is the question of
the independent neuron code.
So is there more activity
if you took into account
the joint activity of all
neurons simultaneously,
so if you had
simultaneous recordings
and took that into account,
versus the pseudo populations
I'm doing where you are
treating each neuron as if they
were statistically independent.
And so this is a very,
very simple analysis.
Here I just did the
decoding in an experiment
where we had
simultaneous recordings
and compared it to using
that same data but using
pseudo populations on that data,
using very simple classifiers.
And so here are the results.
What I found was
that in this one case
there was a little
bit extra information
in the simultaneous
recordings as
compared to the
pseudo populations.
But you know, it wouldn't really
change many of your conclusions
about what's happening.
It's like, you know, maybe
a 5% increase or something.
And then this has been seen
in a lot of the literature.
This is the question
of temporal precision
or what is sometimes
called temporal coding.
What happens, you know,
some of the experiments
I was using 100 millisecond
bin, sometimes I was using 500.
What happens when you
change the bin size?
What happens, this is
pretty clear, again,
from a lot of studies
that I've done,
when you increase the bin size,
generally the decoding accuracy
goes up.
What you lose is
temporal precision,
because now you're blurring
over a much bigger area.
So in terms of your
understanding what's going on,
you have to find the
right point between having
a very clear result by having
a larger bin versus you
caring about the
time information
and using a smaller bin.
And I haven't seen that I need
like one millisecond resolution
or a very complicated
classifier that's
taking every single spike
time into account to help me.
But again, I haven't explored
this as fully as I could.
So it would be
interesting for someone
to use a method [INAUDIBLE]
that people really
love to claim that things are
coded in patterns in time.
You know, if you
want to, go for it.
Show me it.
I've got some data available.
Build a classifier that does
that and we can compare it.
But I haven't seen it yet.
So a summary of
the neural coding.
Decoding allows you to examine
many questions, such as is
there a compact code.
So is there just a few neurons
that has all the information.
Is there a dynamic code.
So is the pattern of
activity that's coding
information changing in time.
Are neurons independent or is
there more information coded
in their joint activity.
And what is the
temporal precision.
And this is, again,
not everything,
there are many other
questions you could ask.
Any other questions
about the neural coding?
Just a few other
things to mention.
So you know, I was talking all
about, basically, spiking data.
But you can also do
decoding from MEG data.
So there was a
great study by Leyla
where she tried to
decode from MEG signals.
Here's just one example
from that paper where
she was trying to decode
which letter of the alphabet,
or at least 25 of
the 26 letters,
was shown to a subject, a human
subject in an MEG scanner.
You know, see is
very nice, you know,
people are not psychic either.
And then at the time, slightly
after the stimulus is shown,
you can decode quite well.
And things are above chance.
And then she went on to
examine position invariance
in different parts of the
brain, the timing of that.
So you can check out
that paper as well.
And as Rebecca mentioned,
this kind of approach
has really taken off in fMRI.
Here are three
different toolboxes
you could use if
you're doing fMRI.
So I wrote a toolbox I
will talk about in a minute
to do neural decoding, and
I recommend it for that.
But if you're going
to do fMRI decoding,
you probably are better off
using one of these toolboxes
because they have certain
things that are fMRI specific,
such as mapping back to voxels
that my toolbox doesn't have.
Although you could,
in principle,
throw fMRI data into
my toolbox as well.
And then all these studies
so far I've mentioned
have had kind of structure
where every trial is exactly
the same length, as
Tyler pointed out.
And if you wanted
to do something
where it wasn't that structured
that well, such as decoding
from a rat running around a maze
where it wasn't always doing
things in the same
amount of time,
there's a toolbox that came
out of Emory Brown's lab that
should hopefully
enable you to do some
of those kinds of analyses.
All right, let me just briefly
talk about some limitations
to decoding, just like Rebecca
did with the downer at the end.
So some limitations are, this
is a hypothesis-based method.
So we have specific questions
in mind that we want to test.
And then we can assess whether
those questions are answered
or not, to a certain degree.
So that's kind of a good thing
but it's also a down thing.
Like if we didn't think
about the right question,
then we're not going to see it.
So there could be
a lot happening
in our neural activity that we
just didn't think to ask about.
And so unsupervised
learning methods
might get at some of that.
And you could see about how
much is the variable of interest
you're interested in, accounting
for the total variability
in a population.
Also, I hinted at this
throughout the talk,
just because information is
present doesn't mean it's used.
The back of the head stuff might
be an example of that or not,
I don't know.
But you just have to
interpret the results
and don't know the
information there.
Therefore, this is the
brain region doing x.
A lot of stuff can
kind of sneak in.
Timing information can be
also really interesting.
I've been exploring this summer.
So if you can know the relative
timing, when information
is in one brain
region versus another,
it can tell you a lot about
kind of the flow of information
the computation that brain
regions might be doing.
So I think that's another very
promising area to explore.
Also, decoding kind of focuses
on the computational level
or algorithmic level, or
really neural representations
if you thought about
Marr's three levels.
It doesn't talk about this kind
of implementational mechanistic
level.
So [INAUDIBLE] it's not
one thing it can do.
Now if you have the flow
of information going
through an area and you
understand that well and what's
being represented,
I think you might
be able to back out some of
these mechanisms or processes
of how that can be built up.
But in and of itself, decoding
doesn't give you that.
Also, decoding methods,
computationally,
can be intensive.
can take up to an hour.
If you do something
really complicated,
it can take you a week to
run something very elaborate.
You know, sometimes
it can be quick
and you can do it
in a few minutes,
but it's certainly a lot
slower than doing something
like an activity index where
you're done in two seconds
and then you have the
wrong answer right away.
Let me just spend like
five more minutes talking
about this toolbox
and then you can all
go work on your projects
and do what you want to do.
So this is a toolbox I made
called the neural decoding
toolbox.
There's a paper
about it in Frontiers
in Neuroinfomatics in 2013.
And the whole point of it was to
try to make it easy for people
to do these analyses
because [INAUDIBLE]..
And so basically, here
is like six lines of code
that if you ran it would do
one of those analyses for you.
And not only is it
six lines of code,
but it's almost literally these
exact same six lines of code.
The only thing
you'd, like, replace
would be your data rather
than this data file.
And so what you can do,
the whole idea behind it
is it's a kind of open
science idea, you know,
I want more transparency
so I'm sharing my code.
If you use my code, ultimately,
if you could share your data,
that would be great
because I think
I wouldn't have been able
to develop any of this stuff
if people hadn't
shared data with me.
I think we'll make a lot
more progress in science
if we're open and share.
There you go, I'm a hippy.
And here's the website for
the toolbox, www.readout.info.
Just talk briefly a little
bit more about the toolbox.
The way it was designed is
around four abstract classes.
So these are kind of
major pieces or objects
that you can kind
of swap in and out.
They're like
components that allow
you to do different things.
So for example, one of the
components is a data source.
This creates the training
and test set of data.
You can separate that
out in different ways,
like there's just a standard
one but you can swap it out
to do that invariance
or abstract analysis.
Or you can do things
like, I guess, change
the different binning schemes
within that piece of code.
So that's one component
you can swap in and out.
Another one are
these preprocessors.
What they do is they apply
pre-processing to your training
data, and then use
those parameters that
were learned on the training
set to do some mechanics
to the test set as well.
So for example, when I was
selecting the best neurons,
I used a preprocessor
that just eliminated--
found good neurons
in the training set,
just used those, and
then also eliminated
those neurons in the test set.
And so there are
different, again,
components you can swap
in and out with that.
An obvious component you can
swap in and out, classifiers.
You could throw in a classifier
that takes correlations
into account or doesn't.
Or do whatever you want here.
You know, use some highly
nonlinear or somewhat nonlinear
thing and see is the
brain doing it that way.
And there's this final piece
called cross validator.
It basically runs the whole
cross validation loop.
It pulls data from
the data source,
creating training and test sets.
It applies the
future preprocessor.
It trains the classifier
and reports the results.
Generally, I've only written one
of these and it's pretty long
and does a lot of
different things,
like gives you different
types of results.
So not just is there
information loss
but gives you mutual information
and all these other things.
But again, if you wanted
to, you could expand on that
and do the cross-validation
in different ways.
If you wanted to get
started on your own data,
you just have to put your data
in a fairly simple format.
It's a format I
call raster format.
It's just in a raster.
So you just have
trials going this way.
Time going this way.
And if it was
spikes, it would just
be the ones and zeros that
happen on the different trials.
If this was MEG data,
you'd have your MEG
actual continuous
values in there.
Again, trials and time.
Or fMRI or whatever.
fMRI might just be one vector
if you didn't have any time.
And so again, this
is just blown up.
This was trials.
This is time.
You can have the little
ones where a spike occurred.
And then what corresponds
to each trial,
you need to give the
labels about what happened.
So you'd have just something
called raster labels.
It's a structure.
And you'd say, OK, on the
first trial I showed a flower.
Second trial I showed a face.
Third trial I showed a couch.
And these could be numbers
or whatever you wanted.
But it's just indicating
different things are
happening in different trials.
And you can also have
multiple ones of these.
So if I want to decode
position, I also
have upper, middle, lower.
And so you can use the same
data and decode different types
of things from that data set.
And then there's this
final information
that's kind of optional.
It's just raster site info.
So for each site you could
have just meta information.
This is the recording
I made on January 14
and it was recorded from IT.
So you just define these
three things and then
the toolbox plug and play.
So with some experience you
should be able to do that.
So that's it.
I want to thank the Center
for Brains, Minds, Machines
for funding this work.
And all my collaborators who
collected the data or who
worked with me to analyze it.
And there is the
URL for the toolbox
if you want to download it.